Why don't we go next to Tommy from
Wisconsin? Tommy from Wisconsin,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hi, David. Can you hear me all right?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Okay. I guess I just
really had a comment about Nikki Haley and, you
know, the possibility and I know it's a ways off
that she might end up as Trump's VP. Sure. But
do you think if he chooses her, will she will.
Speaker 3: He will. Trump used.
Speaker 2: Her name.
Speaker 1: Nikki Haley or.
Speaker 2: Use her Indian name?
Speaker 1: What do you think? What do you think
timing her? Which name do you think he'll use?
Speaker 2: I suspect he'll probably just refer
to her as Nikki Haley. So he doesn't end up
slaughtering her like Sue, Chin Tendulkar or.
Speaker 1: So here's the thing. This is the thing.
So for people who don't know, Nikki Haley's given
name was actually Nima Radha Randhawa. Okay. So
her name now. Now she goes by Nikki Haley. There's
two sides to this. First, Trump would love to give
her the Barack Hussein Obama treatment, which
would be to refer to her as Namrata Randhawa.
The problem, though, is Trump really struggles
with names, as we know, you know, Susan Tendulkar
and Virat Kohli. And when he went to India and
tried to pronounce the names of cricket players,
it went really badly. So that would be a reason
for Trump to stay away from that. But I think
Trump would love to use her birth name as a
way to subtly criticize her with the kind of
xenophobia that he's known for.
Speaker 3: Makes sense to me.
Speaker 1: Well, we'll see what happens, though.
Speaker 2: Right? Absolutely.
Speaker 1: All right, Tommy, that's beautiful.
Speaker 2: Thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: Great to hear from you. Appreciate it.